bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france on vient donc de la
prendre à un nouveau foyer de
contamination avec le variant
britannique vient d'être détecté près de
marseille est ce qu il ya de sérieuses
raisons aujourd'hui d'être inquiet quant
à la circulation de cette souche du
virus sur notre territoire
oui évidemment on le voit en angleterre
on voit qu'on a deux mois de décalage
avec des courbes anglaise donc ça a
commencé
q3 là bas donc on peut s'attendre à
avoir une forte augmentation sur le
variante circulent il est déjà sur le
territoire et il faudra attendre encore
plusieurs semaines pour avoir une vision
assez globale de l'état de circulation
cette souche en france d'angleterre et
topiques connaît un gros pic dans deux
mois on aura notre réponse a priori oui
une vaste opération de dépistage telle
que celle qui réalisait en ce moment
même à bagneux est ce que selon vous
c'est la meilleure réponse à apporter
pour faire face à ces mutations du virus
à celle britannique en l'occurrence pas
que le dépistage malheureusement c'est
une des stratégies des pistes et isolé
puis prendre les mesures nécessaires en
cas d'augmentation de l'épidémie est que
le gouvernement est à priori en train de
faire et vous semble aller dans le bon
sens ces mesures prises par le
gouvernement
l'avenir le dira si le chiffre des
sandwichs je pense qu'on est tous en
avance tout ce petit à petit on a une
nouvelle variante qui est plus agressive
donc il faudra sûrement un petit peu
durcir les choses il faut toujours
rappeler qu'on fonctionne en fonction de
mes décisions par rapport à l'attention
hospitalière c'est le seul critère qui
nous pousse à prendre ce genre de
décisions l'hôpital est en tension les
leaders et à son saturé
s'il est libéré à était plus disponible
si le personnel soignant a été plus
libre aussi on aurait moins de tensions
sociétales moines de mesures sanitaires
à prendre
vous parlez de la liberté du personnel
citoyen qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que vous
sous-entendez moins de tension tout
simplement alors plus de plus de lits
plus de personnel disponible en ce qui
concerne cette souche britannique
on est vu un cas donc été détectée dans
une maternelle une école maternelle de
bagneux est-ce qu'ils posent davantage
de questions ce virus mutant quant à la
circulation au sein des élèves des
enfants est ce que bon qu'il faudrait
davantage tester au sein des écoles
élémentaires c'est probable le virus
anglais la nouvelle mutation à une
contagion contagiosité de plus de 40 à
80 % fait une fourchette large mais la
plus petite manchette et + 40 %
si les enfants sont plus vecteurs
effectivement il faudra peut-être plus
j'ai des pistes et on a vu que
l'angleterre a décidé de fermer ses
écoles en début de semaine s'est fait
une piste qu'ils ont prises et il faudra
suivre ça de très près dans nos écoles
on évoque ces derniers jours ce
couvre-feu avancé de deux heures dans
certains départements est ce que c'est
la meilleure solution pour contrôler
l'épidémie est ce que finalement celle
qui reste la plus efficace n'est pas le
confinement difficile de répondre à
cette question je pense qu'on a un peu
tous testés et qu on avance petit à
petit en fonction de la situation qui
évolue
peut-être que le premier pas c'est déjà
un couvre-feu renforcer avant de décider
de d'emblée un gros confinement si le
coureur encore fait ne fonctionne pas y
passeront le cap supérieur
il est chez de peut-être d'essayer de
nouvelles options pour ne pas trop
restreint de l'année la population ni
l'économie d'un mot comment est ce que
vous voyez
l'évolution de la situation à court
terme ces prochains jours ces prochaines
semaines la certitude de nouvelles
variantes qu'il faut explorer fut
difficile de se prononcer je pense que
on essaie tous de faire au mieux la
réponse personne ne l'a on avance de
surprise en surprise on essaie tous
d'anticiper ce qui est loin d'être
facile
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris tant de
réagir
sur notre antenne marie giraud héraud
vice-présidente du collectif santé en
danger